[Music]
another question here from jennifer
how much of the tv show hoarders is
actually real versus a staged
exaggeration and what does the
professional organizer community think
about these shows well ryan and i were
just at the emmys and they sat us at the
table with one of the hosts of hoarders
which somebody planned
um and his wife uh she was lovely and
they
were talking to us about hoarding
and the show hoarders and even he he was
like i was seeing my own hoarding
through these people but it was easy for
me to
laugh and ridicule the stage five orders
because they have
dead pets in the freezer or feces on the
floor in the bathroom or they have
blocked exits and at least i'm not that
bad right
we were on rachel cruz's show recently
let's put a link to that in the show
notes we did like a 20 30 minute tv show
spot with her we talked about the five
stages of hoarding and the truth is the
first stage of hoarding most people
are stage one hoarders right light
clutter in more than one room and you're
a stage one hoarder yeah and no
noticeable odors
well you must be stage two then
wait a minute
so julia we were talking to
matt about
boarding
and about the tv show hoarders and it is
a accurate representation of these
people's lives now here's the thing
these are
extreme cases obviously it's we don't
feature stage one hoarders on the tv
show hoarders because like that's
everyone right what
we need to sensationalize things so we
need to see stage five we need to see
the blocked exits we need to see the
tiny pathways so you can barely walk
through someone's home
and so yes it is sensationalized for tv
and edited in a way that makes it more
compelling because let's face it we've
also driven by a hoarder's yard a
hoarder's house i'm not compelled in the
sense that i want to watch their yard
for 30 minutes so of course a tv show
has to make it more compelling but you
work in people's houses all the time who
are hoarders they may not be stage five
all the time but you're seeing stage two
three four hoarders
and it's very real
it's absolutely real yeah yeah i mean
i've seen the show hoarders as well um
and i recently read matt paxton's book
about legacy list and letting go and i
found it helpful in thinking about you
know later in life the things that i
wanted to be remembered for in terms of
material possessions uh yes i see
hoarded homes regularly
the home that i was speaking about
earlier with all of the paper covering
the desk was an example of that and i
think a lot of people that i work with
are not they're aware that there's a
problem but they're they don't see
things the same way that an outsider
would see it because they've got so used
to it yeah and they do a lot of just
stuff shifting they're just turning
things around you know they'll do
they'll just move things from one room
to the next um what i consider what i do
is somewhere between what you see on the
home edit and what you see on hoarders
it's very much in the middle
one thing that i find so fascinating is
that when i work with people in
hollywood which i do sometimes because
i'm located in la they don't allow me to
take pictures of their home or videos of
their home so
what we see on the home that it is these
celebrities super excited to come in but
we are not seeing a celebrities who are
in hoarded homes because of the shame
that they have i see these people sadly
they don't let me take a selfie like you
know with them because they don't want
they don't want anyone to know that it
was like that but um whether you're a
celebrity or not um this is a very real
problem that i see all the time and i
see it in homes that you don't see in
movies so you know some in a lot of
movies you see like the really wealthy
home with the whole staff working in
there and it looks pristine and
immaculate i see those homes in santa
monica and beverly hills and brentwood
that are also hoarded so i see
like i said it's somewhere between where
i exist is between the two so i would
say there is reality very much so to the
show hoarders but as you said it is
sensationalized
yeah it's almost like like so these
homes you're talking about it's like
these beautiful pieces of art really
uh-huh but then when you cram it full of
stuff it takes that beauty away from it
it's like throwing a cake at mona lisa
yeah right yeah
yeah
yeah too soon josh yeah and i i mean i'm
really just there to support them they
already feel pretty terrible about the
state of things and um you know i often
wonder at the show hoarders how they get
people to agree to be on the show
because many of the people i work with
really strongly do not want any evidence
of anyone knowing that it was even close
to where they live where we were yeah i
feel like the hoarders episodes are like
people who are just like completely
desperate like they're just so desperate
they're like fine let's film it help me
get rid of stuff what's fascinating to
me and i'm kind of going off the rail
here a little bit what's fascinating to
me is that show a lot of the times
has instances where the home isn't safe
so there's so much stuff
and there's so much weight that it
structurally changes the house
and then they always are like hey we
your house is unsafe to live in like you
need to move out and so they'll move out
but they always end up moving back in
like always just yeah so like for the
show they move out and then there's like
a follow-up and it's like oh yeah
six months later they just moved right
back into the house and nothing really
changed yeah and the reason nothing
changes is it don't get to
the why
if you don't understand why
you want to let go or why you're holding
on so tightly
boarding is part of the ocd spectrum
it's the same thing as spartanism but
just the other side of the spectrum
spartans can't hold on to anything
they keep letting go unintentionally
slipping off right it's like they have
butterfingers and they can't hold on to
anything relationships stuff careers
cities etc
orders can't let go of anything and so
they cling
tightly
and the only reason we cling tightly is
because we don't see the benefits of
letting go
i can briefly share a personal story of
how i relate to this so i'm i never
identified as a hoarder at all however a
lot of my life experience has very much
have informed the way that i approach
organizing and as i was mentioning
earlier with finding a therapist you
have to ultimately be the one asking for
help so
i have been in a rehab setting in my
past and when i saw people who came in
there who were there by intervention by
their families by court order who had to
be there for their drug or alcohol
addiction those people were much less
likely to get well to get better than
people who were there on their own
accord yeah and so um even if it isn't
hoarding i can relate to that because i
have seeked help in the past i had an
eating disorder and i went to seek
treatment myself and ultimately i
believe that's why i got better it
wasn't because somebody else asked me to
do it
it was because i was ready and i was
ready to get help at that time but the
other people that were there again
through intervention not so much and so
with that show hoarders i love that the
show exists because if it motivates
people to get help that's fantastic i'm
sure some people do watch it because
they just want to feel better about
themselves i mean i think a lot of us
watch tv to unwind and like look at how
much of a hot mess that house is or like
any reality show look how much better i
am but if it leads people to seek help
that's fantastic and i'm glad it exists
yeah that's a yeah that's a great point
like you can't help someone who doesn't
want to be helped
that's absolutely true did you enjoy
this standalone patreon highlight if so
you can listen to full episodes of the
minimalists private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free